okay good afternoon everyone I'm
assistant chief Constable Richard ocone
the lead for operational policing in
gloucestershire
I'm going to read a statement about the
incident in Tewkesbury this morning
due to the fact a number of inquiries
are ongoing
I hope you'll appreciate I won't be in a
position to go into more detail at the
end or take any further questions
just after 9 A.M this morning we
received a call from someone telling us
about a threat to a teacher at
Tewkesbury Academy
minutes later we received the call from
the ambulance service
telling us a male teacher had been
stabbed in a corridor at the school
he was taken to hospital with a single
star wound and remains in a stable
condition
it was initially thought that the
suspect had fled the scene and hidden
himself within the school grounds
our officers including specialist
trained armed police attended and
carried out a thorough search
this search was both complex and
meticulous in nature as we sought to
ensure there were no further injured
parties as well as seeking the arrest of
the suspect
the academy was locked down and two
neighboring schools were asked to close
their doors as a precaution
specialist resources including the
National Police Air Service and plane
close officers were deployed to search
The Wider area and thanks to their
efforts the suspect was safely arrested
by Firearms officers in Stoke Orchard at
11 o'clock this morning
a knife was seized during that arrest
searches have continued in order to
ensure that there are no further
casualties and we can now confirm that
no one else was injured in this attack
at this stage the motivation behind the
attack is unclear and at this time there
is no evidence to suggest is Terrorism
related however we are keeping an open
mind while further inquiries are carried
out
the suspect a teenage boy from
Tewkesbury was arrested on suspicion of
attempted murder and remains in police
custody
this was clearly a very distressing
incident and our thoughts are with the
victim their family and everyone
impacted by what happened here at the
school
we are working with the school and other
agencies to ensure appropriate support
is available and local people will see
more police in the area over the coming
days as the investigation continues
thank you